the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is that it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
I'm Patrick Coleman and today we're
bringing you an interview between our
associate director Brian Keating the
astrophysicist and author of the recent
book losing the Nobel Prize with one of
the preeminent scientific minds of the
20th and 21st century Freeman Dyson
you have such a remarkable career you've
been an inspiration for many of us uh
younger physicists throughout the
generations you have that rare quality
uh which is not only do you have great
uh longevity of your ideas and influence
but you've had the Good Fortune to to go
through so many uh different generations
of physicists and see so many different
levels of physics throughout your career
and you've not only had great impact on
my career and other people's careers but
you've influenced popular culture in a
way that few physicists have in fact I'm
going to give a quote that Oliver Sacks
the late great Oliver sack said of you
he said a favorite word of Freeman's
about doing science and being creative
is the word subversive
Freeman you feel that it's rather
important that not only you be Crea you
be Orthodox but you also be subversive
and you Freeman have done that all your
life I wonder this is me speaking now if
you've thought about the different
ingredients behind your intellectual
capacity in particular for the
creativity and Imagination that we so
deeply are interested here in the Arthur
C Clarke Center
yeah well it's more true of of of
Oliver's accident it is of me and he's
he's a lot he's been a lot more
subversive than I have but uh no of
course I like to be subversive but the
most important work I did in fact was
just the opposite it's it was
ended up very conservative I was hoping
so to upset the whole Apple path of
physics
and what actually came out was that the
old theories were good and
so I had to accept that that that's the
way nature thinks and that's the way we
have to think too so
so the actual work I was doing wasn't
subversive at all although my intentions
were
you failed at being subversive how
radical of you that quite often happens
that you you hope to create a revolution
and do end up deciding after all that
the experts were righted
so for the benefit of our listeners who
may not be familiar with the revolution
you're talking about could you expound
upon it briefly yeah well this was in
the 1940s
that we had a theory of quantum and
electrodynamics which was the theory of
atoms and radiation these are the basic
theory that was a
required for understanding physics or
understanding what atoms do how they
interact with light
but the theory was mathematically a mess
it it it it was producing stupid answers
which are obviously wrong
so everybody was thinking that oh we
have to have something radical in use
some wonderful new ideas
and it turns out as my work was actually
just to fix up the mathematics to get
rid of a lot of the mathematical
nonsense and what was left over turned
out to be correct so in the end we
rehabilitated the old Theory rather than
creating a new one
very interesting so one thing I'm always
curious about and I tend to ask is one
of my uh favorite saw horses on these
podcasts is whether or not creativity is
like mathematics or even great art in
that it could be or can it be in your
opinion can it be taught or is it
something you can merely nurture uh and
if you're not born with a certain amount
of creativity imagination as a physicist
or as an intellect can you can you
actually learn or teach somebody to be
creative
so the answer is yes I mean surprisingly
so that actually even Mozart had a
teacher
namely Haydn I mean if you look at
great musicians and great great artists
and great scientists they all had
mentors and at least the Stars I know
and
in case
it's not it's an unconscious process of
course you don't sit down and teach
how to make great music but you just
make some music yourself try it out it's
a mostly matter of practice
but practice Guided by other people's
knowledge and experience
but I always say about for myself that
I I do both
calculating science and also writing
English and us
cases I always say it's the fingers that
do the thinking that
I can I can't really think about a
problem in the abstract just
walking in the country and thinking that
doesn't work I have to sit down at the
desk
and actually calculate something or
actually write something and as the
fingers move somehow the thoughts come
and I think that's two of many of us
that uh and of course it's mature
musicians particularly the fingers
really are doing the thinking in the
case of music
and I don't I think science in many ways
is is very much the same
absolutely
okay
so bringing or connecting those two
digital practices of uh using your
fingers both mathematics and in
literature writing
um how do you how do you find you know
switching between the two is it a
natural phenomena for you that you that
you're it's relatively simple for you to
switch between between writing English
as you say and and writing mathematics
no it was very much a a
the conscious decision I
was very happy doing science when I was
young and science is really a young
man's game and then
it comes to the midlife crisis when
you're 40 years old
and you suddenly realize you're not so
smart as all these young people around
you and
you better find another line of work and
so
in my case the other line of work was
writing and it turned out to be a very
productive
Enterprise I I wrote a number of books
they sold well and
I found in many ways it's opened writing
Books open doors and it widened my
circle the friends very much so it
became I became much more of a public
figure rather as a writer than I was as
a scientist so I've enjoyed the second
half of my life
it was a a conscious decision that
science is really a young man's game
whereas writers can continue to write
it's into the 90s and they don't seem to
deteriorate so much
so in that case it certainly has worked
out very well
again
and the next question I want to ask is
the um is the broad Panorama that is um
that is characteristic of your work from
spanning uh the very most uh deepest
underpinnings of the atom and the
nucleus and that all ranging all the way
out into the deep Interstellar voids and
I wonder you know when you think about
the distant future you know I've heard
you speak about the the four revolutions
that you've witnessed in your lifetime
beginning with the space
Revolution and kind of the the the the
the generation that we're in now with
the exploration of space But even that
started with you during the during
um and your your you experienced the
early part of of the Space Race and and
even
um living in in England during the the
war and having to uh undergo some of the
uh shelling by by Hitler's forces using
uh Werner Von Braun's technology analogy
I wonder you mentioned once that uh in
some ways you were influenced by Arthur
C Clarke who is of course the namesake
of this of this organization that we're
a part of and I wonder
um
has it um has this you know capacity for
spanning the very small to the very
large is that is that in any way did
that just come naturally to you that
that you were able to think the small
picture to the big picture was that
something that came easily to you yes I
mean I have a source attention span
that's
I like to jump around from one thing to
another that so that's just my
temperament
and it's so it means I don't generally
think Deep Thoughts I'm usually usually
just listening to the latest gossip and
that's what I mostly do I mean it so
there really are two kinds of scientists
the Deep thinkers and there are problem
solvers
the Deep thinkers of course are the most
important they're the people who really
Revere the most people like Einstein and
Heisenberg and
the Iraq the people who solve big
problems by
sitting down and really
staying with one problem for 10 years
until they have it
and that's not my style I just I I can
work very hard on a problem for a few
weeks and then either I solve it or I
don't in either case I've I've finished
so I go ahead and do something else
which means that I don't dig so deep but
I do
I
I spread more broadly
and just we need both kinds
but I certainly have enormous respect
for both for the good problem solvers
like my teacher Hans beta who was a
absolute champion
Problem Solver it's also not a deep
thinker and and there are others of
course like Ed Whitton my colleague and
friend in Princeton who has done nothing
but deep thinking of his life
so one thing that you've been
particularly in the news for in the last
few years especially so with the
discovery of a remarkable star that
seemed to have a lot of unusual activity
that's colloquially known as Tabby's
star this this star that had activity
that couldn't be explained at least
initially by ordinary astrophysical
phenomena and it was conjectured there
might be an advanced signals of an
advanced technology or civilization that
might be somehow orbiting this star and
it sort of evoked a a renewed or
rekindle an interest in what are known
as Dyson spheres and I wondered if you
could first describe the inspiration for
that it has been said that you credited
science fiction author Olaf Stapleton
with perhaps planting a seed that
germinated the idea of the Dyson Sphere
at first I wonder if could you describe
the the Genesis of that idea and and if
we have time I'd like to explore the
topic of other civilizations and maybe
sending life from Earth out to other
civilizations but first on Dyson spheres
was that influence in any way by by the
writing of uh Olaf yes well this is a
little bit complicated because the whole
notion of Dyson Sphere is a
misunderstanding and so I mean I have to
explain what I actually was was trying
to do and what actually happened which
was quite different so
that there was a
couple of friends of mine
Philip Morrison and Giuseppe coconi who
were physicists at Cornell they had the
idea of listening for alien
civilizations by radio it was a time
when radio telescopes were just getting
good so they proposed to listen for
alien signals in the sky
by radio and that sounded like a very
good a very good idea and uh so I I was
quite excited about that but I asked
them the question well what do you do if
this aliens don't want to communicate
and how do you detect non-communic
non-communicating aliens and the answer
which I came to was you
look for Waste heat that any advanced
civilization if it has a big industry or
big population would have to get rid of
a lot of waste Heat and the only way you
can get rid of waste heat in the large
scale is radiating it into space so it
becomes infrared radiation so what you
should look for is infrared sources in
the sky objects in the sky which are
infrared
radiating a lot of waste heat away in
the form of infrared
so I suggested that and published this
in
magazine science that was about 50 years
ago
and
so waited to see what would happen but
unfortunately I used the word bias
biosphere
to describe
the habitat of these aliens you were
looking for
they would be living in some kind of an
environment and this environment this
habitat would have an outside surface
and what you would actually see was the
warm outside surface of whatever the
aliens had built
and but I used the word biosphere and
the science fiction writers
misunderstood that to be in a big round
ball which of course wasn't at all but I
had in mind and the real habitat will be
much more like a just a collection of
orbiting objects
in space which would have a big surface
but they would have to be
to disconnected objects orbiting around
so that they that didn't require to be
physically very strong
that they could just be some big
balloons with aliens living inside
anyhow so the science fiction writers
got a wrong idea of that
but the the right idea the actual
picture of aliens orbiting around stars
in big balloons actually does come from
a science fiction writer Olaf Stapleton
and he was describing the the
advanced civilizations in a book called
star maker which is a book one of my
favorites science fiction books I mean
it belongs to this genre which I call
see a fiction it's not really science
and fiction but it's a combination of
Theology and fiction
which Stapleton was particularly good at
so that picture of the
Galaxy with its
alien civilizations
absorbing the light
and they're turning it in for infrared
that's clearly described
in that book of Stapleton so it is in
fact where I got it from
sticking on the topic of potential
extraterrestrial intelligence and why we
might not have seen
um the the evidence for such a existence
of such extraterrestrial intelligence
there's a famous so-called Fermi Paradox
which is if you calculate the abundance
of alien civilizations potentially with
a modicum of of realism in terms of
physical properties that would be needed
or even just the probability of such
civilizations arising you come up with a
probability that's uh greater than zero
and fermi's famous Paradox was you know
where are they and if there's if there's
even a slight probability given enough
time there should be some some degree of
probability that they would have visited
and made contact or produced signal
animals that are potentially visible to
Earth civilization so I wonder how do
you reconcile the the in your mind what
what are some of the more plausible
solutions to the Fermi paradox
I don't regard that really as a paradox
I think I mean it's a mystery that's not
the same thing I mean the the universe
is full of mysteries that's that's just
one of the biggest of them but there are
all sorts of mysteries and one of the
big mysteries of course is the origin of
life we don't know how we originated and
we have no idea whether that was just a
colossal accidents which was enormously
and actually but it had just it happened
and with the result
or we might be that it's quite a common
occurrence and that for some reason life
doesn't survive very long that it has
so many bad things can happen that
life may be quite common in the universe
but it usually goes extinct so I mean
all sorts of possible explanations
because I don't regard it as strange
that we haven't discovered aliens I just
it's a mystery why
uh
we don't find aliens and
I'm always expecting to find them I
think I mean but I won't claim I can
calculate the probability there's no way
you can calculate the probability on the
basis of one event and
we only know one kind of life
that's us and so whether it's probable
or improbable we just don't know in the
question of you know whether or not we
should be looking uh for life that looks
like us we've talked about this at one
time but the you know is is it you think
it's a necessary precursor that life
follow some sort of pattern that's
reminiscent of the way nature seems to
work on Earth absolutely not I mean to
nature always has more imagination than
we have sometimes that's so if ever this
so if if you want to guess what you're
going to discover it's not really a
discovery
so the next topic I wanted to talk up
about was potential ways to visit or
send our
portions of our species out into the
interstellar medium within our galaxy
and you had
um actually a very storied history with
um with space flight including working
on the so-called Orion Project and I was
wondering with the recent developments
including as we record this in March of
uh of 2018 or only last month did Elon
musk's and and SpaceX send a Tesla
Roadster into uh into the solar system
with an orbit that he initially said at
least would last for a billion years or
so and the question of of getting even
beyond our solar system using Advanced
propulsion systems I wonder first could
you describe what the Orion program was
about
and its current status as well and then
we could get into
um where you see this might be going in
the in the future
good well of course you're in Milner the
Russian
supporter of wild ideas
is is doing very well he has this
breakthrough project which he has just
established with real money and so he is
actually pushing ahead with what he
calls an Alpha Centauri mission that is
an Interstellar mission
I think this is wonderful that is this
is quite new only started a few months
ago and we have no idea really what's
coming going to come out of it but it
obviously is the right sort of a project
if you want to go go ahead with
ambitious
new technology
what I was doing with project Orion that
was now what 60 years ago it's a
was very different I mean that was
by comparison a very modest
project to use nuclear bombs to drive a
spaceship
and that was something we really knew
how to do nuclear bombs are in a way
very simple things they are they're just
big packages of energy that you could
explode
and you can use them for all kinds of
purposes particularly murdering people
so we wanted to use nuclear weapons for
doing something different it wasn't
murdering people
and uh so the the project was actually
started here in San Diego
with the general atomic company which is
still here
and so we actually had a project
to build this
nuclear-powered spaceship which we
called Orion but that was not an
Interstellar Mission it was very
definitely solar system it it could
reach velocities of the order of
30 kilometers per second which is the
speed the earth goes around the Sun so
it's a very good speed for a solar
system Mission but it's not at all good
for Interstellar so Orion is from from
that point of view was so rather simple
and conservative project they would have
had enormous consequences
it would have meant she really cheap and
massive
missions inside the solar system
visiting planets and satellites and
comets
so it was a great shame it didn't go
forward
on the other hand the reasons for
stopping it was in fact a good reason
that
it was
extraordinarily messy when you explode
Bombs all over the place you needed a
large number of bombs for each Mission
the order of two thousand permission so
it meant a huge amount of radioactivity
beings spewed around all over the place
including the planet Earth
so we calculated what we knew about the
effects of radioactivity on human health
and as far as we could tell it it worked
out that every Mission we flew we would
probably kill roughly one person but
that was considerable uncertainty might
have been as many as 10 but possibly
have been a hundred so anyway I thought
it was quite unacceptable and I think
the public considered it unacceptable
then and even much more so now so I I
would say it's a dead project for good
reasons it's simply
it was
too filthy to be tolerated by a
civilized society
so anyway with that so it's
I don't regret having worked on it it
was exciting at the time
but I don't regret having
killed it I actually
justified in the Senate hearing to
ratify the Test Ban Treaty which made
Orion impossible so I'm sort of proud of
that too
very good yeah we'll get back to
politics a little bit later hopefully
um but um well actually why don't we go
to that now so you mentioned these
projects which in some sense were
nucleated either by General atomics I've
mentioned the connection to the SpaceX
which is a private company
and it seems like the uh in many ways a
lot of big projects are being undertaken
not by governments not by entities that
have you know vastly Superior fortunes
even though there are you know very many
wealthy uh billionaires that are funding
prizes like Breakthrough listen and uh
and also Elon musk's for-profit
companies what do you think of the new
money kind of influence that's occurring
in in science to guide projects and
directions and pursue goals of
philanthropists rather than goals of
Nations as things were might have done
in the in the early parts of your career
yes well I mean all in favor of private
money but that's not new of course I
mean astronomy has always been supported
with private money
the Czech telescopes in in Hawaii which
are doing wonderful work in astronomy
these are ground-based telescopes they
were all paid for by Mr Keck
we have a lot of tradition in astronomy
of being supported with private money
and it's certainly private money is much
more pleasant to work with you don't
have to write proposals all the time you
don't have to write progress reports
every three months it's a much more
efficient use of money if you can get it
privately
on the other hand
it's also true that the government is
doing extremely well people the public
is not aware of how wonderfully well the
government has been doing in recent
years I mean the capital mission is a
great example that mission which
discovered 4 000 planets sit around
other stars that was all done with
government money
very efficiently I mean so the
government actually is good at that too
it's it's we need both
one shouldn't put them down just because
they happen to be governments and
what the government is not doing good at
is taking risks
and so if you have something which is
risky then much better do it privately
and that's why the private companies are
doing so well at the moment because if
you want to have a really much cheaper
space propulsion system especially space
launch system which is really cheap
you've got to make it risky and and
because most of the expense of the
government programs
come from this being so risk-averse
everything has to be checked over 25
times
and the paperwork is horrendous
and that's the consequence of not taking
risks so that's why the private
companies can do much better it seems
like space launch which they're starting
to get doing now
being risk versus of course just a way
of making everything expensive
so switching in like the switch from my
controversial subject like politics to a
less controversial one religion if you
don't mind
um so uh you're known for practicing
Christian as a practicing Christian or a
non-denominational Christian I guess
specifically so I guess well maybe
instead of me telling you what you are
because you could you uh maybe describe
uh the role that religion plays in your
life or has traditionally played in your
life uh if you don't mind and then I
have some follow-up questions on the
relationship between religion and
Science and more interest to me of more
interest to me the relationship of
scientists to religion um I think I
think it's actually a fascinating
subject so how do you describe your is
it is it was it from your upbringing or
how was your upbringing sort of
theologically speaking and then how did
you evolve over time
yeah well I I I said
answer the second question first it I'm
a non-believing
but practicing Christian and
which I think is is
actually uh
was a very large fraction of the
practicing Christians are in my church
in Princeton which is Presbyterian the
they don't care whether you believe
everything that's not really the point
it's a community and and it's the the
the the the community of people who have
a
loyalty to the church which is based on
other things rather than belief that the
community it has a very important use
component that takes care of teenagers
there's a lot of activities for
teenagers in the church
they have wonderful music they have
several choirs and they have of course
the Liturgy the
the order of service and above all they
have the the literature the Bible and
all the the Bible is still the greatest
work of English literature in
both historically and at the present day
and that's what the religion actually
gives us whether or not you believe in
the details of
whether Jesus really existed or whether
he was a Divine or human and I I'm
simply not interested in that I think
clearly Jesus did exist and he's a
wonderful
source of wisdom
and so I I have enormous respect for him
but I don't worship him and I think the
same is true of Jews of course even more
that the memory of my Jewish friends are
practicing but not believing that's
that's not at all unusual and that's
probably true of Muslims too and and you
know it's it's a
that's I think that's a happier State of
Affairs you don't have to worry about
whether everything you told is true
and you certainly don't have to blame
people who think differently from
yourself
and I should also mention I mean that I
was brought up in the Church of England
which is
in England of course religion is sort of
a question of class that if you're upper
class your church of England if you're a
lower class you're Presbyterian or
Baptist
so it's very much of a stratified
social distinction and so I had had a
sister who became Catholic because she
couldn't stand the
snobbery and the
Episcopalian Church so she became a
Catholic and so when I was in England
visiting my sister I became Catholic too
I was went to mass with my sister felt
very comfortable there and
now I have a brother who is a
presbyterian minister
so I feel very comfortable with her and
when I go to
to hear her preach in her church
and
so it doesn't matter to me whether it's
Catholic or Protestant or
Episcopalian whatever you want to or for
that matter Jewish
I wonder you know many of our colleagues
don't share The ecumenical thoughts that
you've expressed I always find it ironic
because you know most Universities at
least in America were set up first as
theological seminaries essentially
Colombia Princeton has a very uh storied
history with the Princeton Theological
Seminary
our greatest universities were sort of
established in this way and now it's
it's basically impossible to you know to
find religious studies on campus or or
at least in many campuses that I'm
familiar with and I wonder if that's a
product of the you know more secular age
that we've that we now live in but in
particular you know I've heard it said
about the National Academy of Sciences
in the United States that over
um 93 or so percent of scientists do not
have a belief in God either our atheist
or do not um or or agnostic with only
seven percent that is to say having a
belief in theism as a traditional
definition of the word I I bet the same
is true of your uh fellows of the Royal
Society as well that there's a large
number of of non-believers and maybe
even active non-believers that is to say
not even not believing but but trying to
convince others not to believe a sort of
and they're sometimes described by your
fellow countrymen Richard Dawkins as uh
militant atheists and and I wonder what
what are your thoughts about about that
and why there is
um so much tension I mean it's it's it's
almost as bad as the the tension is
between you know philosophers and
physicists
um it's actually much worse than that
but uh why do you think there is such a
such a
um an innate resistance to to religion
on the part of scientists as a as a
general rule
yes I think it's tremendously
exaggerated by the media I mean Richard
Dawkins who happens to
be the most notorious of these people
and he's a militant atheist and I think
he does a lot of harm his sort of
telling young people you have to make a
choice either religion or science but
not both and I think that does a lot of
harm he actually he turns off a lot of
young people who happen to be religious
Believers thinking they can't be
scientists which is absolutely not true
of course in the past of course I mean
Newton of course it was a very Pious
Christian
and a very serious Christian and most of
the Great
scientists of the past were Believers
and until recently
that the change came in in the 19th
century in the case of Princeton a
person
University was a religious Foundation
what happened in the 19th century was it
became secularized and then
the
sociological Seminary was founded to
take care of the religious part of
Princeton University which was really a
split in the university the Theological
Seminary became independent and does the
theology Princeton is secular
and when he lived side by side and so
that's been the solution in many places
so you separate out the
religious part
and the reason why that happened is
because
very complicated it's a certain it's
just pop
it's it's partly just due to the
American Constitution which makes a
separation between
politics and religion which is certainly
good
on the whole healthy firm yes but so
that encouraged the
universities to become secular
but of course the same thing happened in
France and in other parts of the world
in in a similar fashion around the same
time
indeed
so um when you uh when you look around
the scientific landscape at least in my
field of cosmology uh there's a notion
that has become almost synonymous with
the Big Bang Theory which is uh which is
the epoch of what's called inflation
this early uh super rapid expansion of
space and time that is theorized to take
place in the very first few Nano Nano
Nano nanoseconds after the big bang and
I wonder uh your thoughts on not on
inflation but um one of the consequences
of inflation at least as as proposed by
many of the theorists including Alan
Guth and and Andre Linde and others who
first worked out the details of the
inflationary Theory down to the level of
perturbation Theory and structure
formation and that is the so-called
Multiverse which seems to suggest that
uh that our universe may not be alone so
not only might there be a Fermi Paradox
within our galaxy or even between
galaxies but there might be additional
room and real estate for fermi's
question to to be asked which is that
there might be an infinite number or
functionally infinite number 10 to the
500th universes have been suggested as
not implausible according to the laws of
string theory and relativistic early
Universe cosmology I wonder first of all
your your thoughts on the Multiverse if
you if you have any and then uh
follow-up question about the
similarities between the sort of
the ability to test or falsify
scientific theories such as the
Multiverse and where they fit into uh
sort of the Orthodox conjectures of
modern science so first on the
Multiverse and then if we have time to
talk about uh whether or not it is how
it fits into traditional definitions of
science
yes well because I'm very skeptical
about the series in general and
so I mean inflation was a beautiful idea
and it's not really a theory it's a sort
of a model it's a it's a mathematical
scheme which is extremely simple
and
there's really very little evidence
from observations
that is true it's a model that's
consistent with the observations
it is probably much simpler than
anything that NATO would have devised
naturally has a habit of being
complicated
and so when we look at things for the
first time we usually have a simple
model in mind
and so we look at a star and we think
it's very simple it's just a big ball of
gas
and you make models of it the problem is
that people who work with models
tend to believe the models
it's it's it's almost impossible to work
seriously on the problem without
believing more than it's really
Justified
and so it tends to become then almost a
religion that's
that you have a
a mathematical scheme which you sort of
becomes
in your own mind somehow true
and then you you think about it as if it
were real nature
but when the time finally comes and you
do the observations nature usually says
it's wrong and
that's what I I tend to to believe much
more what nature is saying than I
believe what the astronomers are saying
so that's a that's my my own temperament
but the fact is that astronomy
is amazingly Rich there's so many
wonderful things we are observing
within inside the universe and those
that's what I'm excited about
then there are all these other things
which are beyond the universe like what
they call the Multiverse for which we
have no observations but nothing but
mathematical speculation I don't find
that so interesting and it's a
almost certainly
it has some elements of Truth
but most unlikely that it's anything
like the real truth and
so anyhow I mean as far as I'm concerned
I leave it alone
other people take it much more seriously
than I do
of course two of your
countrymen had sort of a difference of
opinion so one was uh Sir Arthur
Eddington who said never believe in
observation until it's been proven by a
theory which of course is the opposite
of most ways that we think of the
scientific method and then uh Carl
popper also said well he said in
contrast that essentially the
predictions of a theory which cannot be
refuted by observation or tested by
evidence that such theories in the
models that are spawned by the by these
theories
would not qualify and his definition is
as counting in as a scientific Pursuit
it might be a fun parlor trick it might
be give give employment to uh to
astrologers and other soothsayers as
popper called them but I wonder if this
notion of falsifiability does that hold
any resonance to you in your opinion did
oh yes it is no I I mean I am really a
agree with Papa or Papa that the science
ought to be verifiable and but there's
of course
an amazing
fact which
that
somehow goes in in the other direction
is
the fact that mathematics has been so
amazingly successful
describing nature and so there is some
kind of
uh
I would say a really a major mystery
that
so much of what we've invented as
mathematicians what looked like pure
mathematics
finally after after
100 years or so
we find it's all there in nature and so
there is a possibility
this is goes against Papa
the by pure mathematics you can actually
predict what nature is going to do and
that that does it does work so so papa
is not the whole story and it's the real
world is a mixture of Papa and Eddington
that's of course that's what makes it so
beautiful that these Mysteries we don't
understand I would like to say science
is really not about things we understand
science is about things we don't
understand that's what makes it exciting
and in that sense of course science and
religion are not so different that both
signs and religion are Mysteries
will we have this amazing ability
which we can't explain
to find out how how nature thinks and I
mean it's I've always liked to say I
mean we we just are monkeys who came
down from the trees rather recently and
it's amazing that a monkey
generates a symphony or
or or
invent stream Theory or anything else I
mean the imagination which we have
wasn't required to survive in the jungle
or when we climbed or when we were
living up in the trees it was somehow
this imagination is a gift from nature
which we don't understand like many
other things
uh one more question before we turn to
the final uh question so I guess the
penultimate question if you if you knew
that there was a God uh what question
would you most like the answer to if you
could sort of circumvent all the
scientific method and hard work if you
could just ask a question of this
omniscient omnipotent being uh what
would that question be
oh well of course
it's it's it's it's it's it's it's a
choice there's some so many Mysteries
and so
I don't know which I would choose but
perhaps
how did Life Begin I think would be sort
of number one in my mind and
he he he probably knows
one would hope so
the job description
okay so I want to spend the last few
minutes talking about uh prizes and uh
you know that I'm quite interested in in
prizes and and you've won so many of
them it would take uh the remaining uh
all the remaining time we have just just
to list them um including one recent one
that I do want to bring up but um in
particular that what I consider to be
the world's most prestigious Accolade of
any kind the Nobel Prize you once said I
think it's almost true without exception
that if you want to win a Nobel Prize
you should have a long attention span
get a hold of some deep and important
problem and stay with it for 10 years
that wasn't my style you've talked about
that but I guess it's clear to me or it
seems clear to me that you never really
saw winning the Nobel Prize as a
priority many people as you know have
considered that you should have uh had a
share of the Nobel Prize that went to uh
the folks along with whom you created a
Quantum electrodynamics of the theory of
quantum electrodynamics I wonder how
this you know you're losing of the Nobel
Prize in in my in my language
um does that have any effect on you or
where do you see the role of such of
such prizes
um some say it's a curse to win a Nobel
Prize T.S Eliot who won the Nobel Prize
for literature said the Nobel Prize is a
ticket to one's own funeral no one has
ever done anything after they won it
you've had such a remarkable career even
since uh since those heady days of
inventing Quantum electrodynamics so I
wonder what are your feelings on prizes
such as the Nobel Prize well I was
recently uh well there's a wonderful uh
it was a Jocelyn Bell George she married
Berner so she's called Jocelyn and now
she's the one who discovered Pulsar
actually that's right the
positive radio sources in the sky which
turned out to be rotating neutron stars
and they have an enormous importance in
the
good
dynamics of the universe and in all
sorts of ways it was one of the biggest
discoveries ever made in astronomy
and she did not get the Nobel Prize
instead her supervisor Anthony huge got
the prize
and she was barely mentioned she she was
then a graduate student when she did the
work
anyway so that's sort of a famous
example of a wrong person getting the
prize and she was visiting Princeton
recently she's a wonderful lady she's
she was only about about 20 which did
the work and and now she's in her 70s I
guess but still going strong
anyway she was visiting Princeton of
course the students asked her the
inevitable question what do you feel
about Dr David Nobel Prize and she said
oh it's wonderful you know it's so much
nicer to have people ask you why you
didn't get the Nobel Prize that who has
them ask you why you did
that's I feel the same way it says
anyhow
but in fact of course we didn't worry
about it it was it really wasn't in Our
Minds when we were doing the work and it
it it I think it's become much more
worried about these days somehow just
because of the media pays so much more
attention to it than they used to and I
I don't in those times when I was
a graduate student I don't think it
actually was talked about so much
certainly we weren't thinking about it
much and it it it's certainly true I did
not deserve it because
I was
mostly just
cleaning UPS or cleaning up the
mathematical mess
it was all just mathematical details
what I was doing all the ideas were came
from the other three
so I'm not unhappy with that at all
one thing I would like to uh to draw
attention to is last week it was
announced that you won the Highland
prize uh and so I went to read the
citation I believe I have it this is
from the National Space Society
organization
and the headline is Freeman Dyson famed
physicist wins the National Space
society's prestigious Robert a Heinlein
Memorial award
so the space Society members have voted
to give Freeman dice in the prestigious
Robert a Heinlein Memorial award this
award honors the work that he has done
as a groundbreaking physicist and
mathematician and has a major thought
leader in the Science and Space
communities over half a century
and there'll be a presentation in Los
Angeles on May 24th through May 27th and
you'll be celebrated there I wonder if
you could give us a preview in any way
of the remarks that you might be
thinking about for your acceptance
speech of this wonderful award
yeah well of course
no I have enormous
respect for Heinlein I I mean I do read
quite a lot of Science Fiction and
timeline was very good as a spinner of
stories and he he I think science
fiction has been important still is
important for getting kids interested in
science and so
guessing the public
interested in supporting science
was the old-fashioned kind who just had
people
strutting around in space
anyhow what I'm going to talk about at
says ceremon is is a sort of an
outrageous comedy about what might
happen in the future that's what I think
science fiction
can contribute to somehow a lighter
touch so you don't
doesn't all have to be so serious and
so I I I I I'm promoting something
called the Noah's Ark egg which is a
vehicle for getting
embryos into space very cheaply so I
think it might in fact have a important
part of our future I mean the important
thing is not humans going into space
important serious Life as a whole it if
you want us if you want to flourish in
the universe one species won't cut it
it's you have to have a million species
living together that's when Nature
really can
take off
and evolve evolution is not something
that's done by one species Evolution
requires a whole ecology and it's a very
complicated and very powerful creative
thing
and I think the Noah's Ark egg might be
the way to do it anyhow that's what I'll
be talking about very good well I know
that you said in the beginning that you
like to get the bad news first but now
the bad news comes at the end that this
interview has to come to an end
uh despite uh my desire to very much
continue to pick your brain but you'll
be around San Diego I know a lot more in
the future as a scholar in Residence
here at the University of California in
San Diego and I appreciate your visit
and congratulations on winning the
Highland award as well thank you Freeman
thank you
this has been into the impossible a
podcast of the Arthur C Clarke Center
for human imagination at UC San Diego
we'd like to thank Our Guest Dr Freeman
Dyson and acknowledge our generous
patrons and sponsors including ViaSat
Inc members of the founders orbit and
the James B ax Family Foundation your
support is much appreciated
to find out more about the Clark Center
and other exciting projects research and
programs as well as how to support our
mission please visit
imagination.ucsd.edu
audio production is by me Patrick
Coleman produced by Patrick Coleman and
Brian Keating the only thing we can be
short of about the future is that it
will be absolutely fantastic
for one
[Music]